Hi!
Convolutional neural networks compute convolutions
on the input like this:
For an image, we take the kernel and slide
it over the input to obtain local weighted
averages everywhere.
Right?
Not always.
See, in the convolution definition the kernel
matrix appears to be flipped:
As the index of the input increases, the index
of the kernel decreases.
But if you do not flip the kernel, you get
the cross-correlation which is the one implemented
as a convolutional layer by many of the deep
learning libraries.
So, when working with a pre-trained CNN, it
is important to know whether it was trained
with convolutions or with cross-correlation
to avoid unexpectedly flipped learned kernels.
But we also see how convolutions are basically
just cross-correlations between input and
kernel; in other words:
a CNN learns a kernel that maximizes correlation
with patterns, specializing the kernel at
detecting patterns in the input.
It’s almost like neural networks are built
as a huge correlation detector.